und im studio begrüße ich jetzt sehr
herzlich andrej melik der botschafter
der ukraine in deutschland schön dass
sie hier bei uns in vielen herzlichen
dank
was ging ihnen was ging ihnen durchs
herz ist sie heute diese bilder gesehen
haben werden auch einen tweet von ihnen
vorliegende dieses historische zentrum
der stadt ihrer heimat das dort so
schrecklich getroffen wurde ja das
stimmt also jede angriffe der erfolg in
den letzten wochen ist auch ein angriffe
gegen uns persönlich gegen mich gehen
meine landsleute aber das was wir
gestern abend gesehen haben und erlebt
haben das war eben der das stadtviertel
wo wir gewohnt haben wo wir weiterhin
wohnen wo unsere kinder groß geworden
sind und das ist ein doppelter schlag
das ist eine doppelte angriff mitten ins
herz das ist etwas was man gar nicht
beschreiben kann also die wie kann das
weitergehen also so viele tage und
werden städte bombardiert jetzt ein
theater krankenhäuser und jetzt ein ein
shopping mall wie soll das weitergehen
ich glaube dass auch die politik hier in
berlin auch reagieren sollte und sich
gedanken machen sollte was was man noch
mehr tun sollte um so etwas zu
verhindern dann sind auch menschen
gestorben und dass das kann man nicht
mehr weiter zu sehen ganz konkret
formulieren sie gerne auch ihre
forderungen was erwarten sie von
deutschland jetzt ja das war schon seit
wochen auf dem tisch liegt nämlich die
us embargo man könnte das auch ein
moratorium nennen und um einen
importstopp zumindest für einen monat
oder zwei monate einzuführen um gas und
öl und kohle nicht mehr aus russland zu
beziehen es ist eine schwere
entscheidung
davon wissen wir aber gleichzeitig
angesichts dieser situation wo wir sehen
diese angriffe die häufen sich immer
mehr zivilisten sterben und wir glauben
dass die zeit schon drei feste um eben
auch diesen schritt zu unternehmen und
zu schauen wir glauben schon dass
brötchen das brötchen sehr wohl dass
auch treffen wir dass er
das er dann vielleicht zwei mal darüber
nicht nachdenken bevor er einen befehl
für solche anschläge gibt bisher gibt es
jedoch keinerlei anzeichen dass diese
wünsche erfüllt werden wie sehr
enttäuscht sie das ja wir sehen dass die
politik natürlich versuchte jetzt
umzudenken und diese abhängigkeit vom
von den russischen energieträger auch zu
verändern aber dass das läuft so langsam
also wir können nicht bis zum herbst
oder bis zum nächsten jahr warten bis
dieser schritt erfolgt wir hoffen dass
das man durchaus in der lage sein kann
hier die bundesregierung auch agiert
damit damit man auch brüchen brötchen
herausforderte er weiß oder er vermutet
dass die deutschen das nicht wagen und
gerade deswegen hat die bundesregierung
können diese waffe in der hand diese
ökonomische sanktion und sie wird
wirklich ins herz treffen und zu
verhindern dass solche anschläge nicht
mehr stattfinden gleichzeitig hat man
das gefühl es ist arg 26 im krieg und es
tritt schon fast eine art schrecklicher
normalzustand an haben sie das gefühl es
besteht die gefahr dass wir uns alle an
diese schrecklichen bilder gewöhnen in
einer art und weise wir hoffen dass das
nicht geschieht das wäre das schlimmste
für für für die menschen aber sie haben
leider recht je länger diese sinnlose
dieser schreckliche krieg sich hinzieht
desto mehr ist die gefahr dass die
menschen einfach nicht mehr reagieren
würden auf diese gräueltaten wie man
darauf normalerweise reagiert deswegen
ist es wichtig schnell zu agieren nicht
wieder abzuwarten auf irgendwelche neue
rote linien die überschritten werden
sondern man muss das einsetzen die
waffen die man hatte und deutschland hat
dieser hebel dieser ökonomischen hebel
und putin hat wirklich angst davor
deswegen man muss nicht mal ab sondern
zu schlagen und verhindern dass solche
dass solche beschlüsse von von den
zivilen opfern in anderen großstädten
doreen nicht mehr stattfinden haben sie
das gefühl und selbst vielleicht ist das
manchmal hinter vorgehaltener hand dass
es vielleicht politiker gibt die sagen
mein gott warum kapituliert man nicht
einfach dieser krieg ist sie russland
ist so übermächtig wie soll man das
schaffen dieses wehren dass wir alle
auch so sehr bewundern in allen ehren
aber warum hört mir nicht auf und warum
geht mir nicht diesen einfachen weg
begegnet ihnen das manchmal ja leider
nach wie vor vielleicht nicht so
dramatisch wie in den ersten kriegstagen
wo man uns wenige stunden vielleicht
tage eingeräumt hat bevor wir nicht
aufgeben und uns nicht ergeben aber
jetzt nach wie vor ist dieser logik noch
hier zu spüren diese philosophie im
politischen berlin dass das schmerzhafte
auch wenn die ukraine gezeigt haben dass
wir wie kämpfen wir sind bereit auch
gegenüber eine über märkte wie russland
da gerade zu stehen und dieses vorrücken
zu stoppen gleichzeitig ist es so dass
man nach wie vor glaubt ja dieses
russland ist unbesiegbar und es ist
falsch das ist nicht der grundsatz an
der auch das politische geschehen hier
bestimmen soll denn wir haben gesehen
wirtschaftlich war russland und bleibt
ein zwerg aber auch militärisch ist das
no 1 1 eine mittelmark vielleicht das
ist keine großmacht keine keine
übermacht wie man es sich vorstellt das
war ein braver und ausgehend aus dieser
aus dieser these glaube ich sage schon
das dass die deutschen uns noch mehr mit
war von unterstützen sollten das
brauchen wir das ist auch ein gutes
investment in der sicherheit deutschland
selbst denn wir wissen nicht wohin
stoppen kann deswegen muss alles tun um
das system putins in der ukraine zu
zerstören da haben wir die chance dass
der frieden in europa tatsächlich die
oberhand gewinnt haben sie manchmal den
eindruck es gibt vielleicht auch etwas
was wir deutschen von den ukrainern
lernen können jetzt wo wir erfolg sehen
wie es sich weiter wert wie es zusammen
steht wie es kämpft so hoffnungslos ist
manchmal auch erscheinen will wir sehen
ihren präsidenten residenz geht er je
tag unermüdlich zu seinem volk spricht
es ist etwas was die ganze welt tief
beeindruckt gibt es etwas was wir lernen
können
ich glaube also wir tun was wir tun
können also wir können nicht anders es
ist nicht so dass wir eine show für die
anderen machen sondern wir haben keine
andere wahl als
uns zu schützen als zu kämpfen denn es
gibt keine alternativen also wenn wir
aufhören das würde bedeuten dass das
theorien als staat
aufhört zu existieren auch das volk wir
sehen zählen menschen mussten ihre
häuser verlassen
jeder vierte ukrainerin oder ukraine
haben ihre heimat schon verlassen ob ein
großteil noch hinter west ukraine aber
viele auch im ausland und deswegen ich
glaube dass die deutschen einfach mal
sich vor augen führen sollten es ist ein
volk ein nachbar volk menschen die
genauso wie hier leben und leben wollen
und dass man dass er sich lohnt auch die
ukraine noch mehr zu unterstützen in
diesem kampf er ist nicht ohne aussicht
wie manche glauben wir werden nicht
aufgeben wir werden nichts preisgeben
und das ist dass dieses gefühl dessen
dass das man dass man für eigene heimat
auch sein leben aufgeben und riskieren
sollen das ist das was glaube ich für
manche deutsche etwas gutes ist zu
schauen es gibt möglichkeiten es gibt
momente im leben wo man alles aufgibt
denn berufe und einfach da städte am
blog posten von keefe um den eigenen
bezirk zu schützen das sind so sachen
die glaube ich auch für manche deutschen
vielleicht ja unmöglich erscheinen aber
dass das könnte eine neue realität sein
für diese verrückte welt von morgen und
wir hoffen dass die deutschen uns
stützen dass sie uns weiterhin
unterstützen nicht nur mit den waffen
aber mit allem was was was gerade in der
ukraine gebraucht wird das heißt andere
wenig botschaft hier bei uns in der
ukraine vielen herzlichen dank für ihren
besuch